[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and i assure you there is did you not
hear that
ah what i said was this is a test of the
national emergency broadcast system were
there a national emergency and there
certainly is what you would see
is video and it would be synced with
audio and the amplitude would be such
that you could understand the words that
i'm saying with ease
i'm sure they would resonate with you
and all we need from you is to find out
whether these things
are the case you can tell us that in the
chat and then we'll know we can do any
troubleshooting that is necessary
so please give us a holler
looks good sounds good all right we'll
see in a few stay put
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 42 you heard
that correctly
number 42 with all of the meaning
implied therein we are here in portland
trying to keep track of everything that
is taking place and i must tell you
it is pushing me to my limit and beyond
are you feeling the same
absolutely i kind of can't believe it
it's a little hard to believe
yes there's so much going on that you
and i haven't even had a chance to uh
check in with each other in advance of
the live stream
here oh my goodness we're under attack
by felids
um all right so how shall we begin
uh well i guess i wanted to remind
people uh that you can ask questions via
super chat
on on youtube so if you're listening to
this later that's that's no longer an
option
uh and that we will be having a private
q a tomorrow at 11 a.m pacific
uh that you access through my patreon
through the dark horse membership tier
at uh at my patreon so uh those
those two things are on the table and
you before we get
before we embark on a lot of sort of
oregon specific evidence of
some of the madness that is taking over
uh so much of the world
right now you wanted to start with a
unity update yeah yes i do want to start
with a unity update the problem is
it's very hard to know exactly what to
say amazing things are up in the land of
unity
we have a vote coming tomorrow where we
will
prune down our six nominees
to a ticket of two who we will draft and
am i not supposed to say that yet uh
okay well if i could ask a favor
of those who are fans of the dark horse
podcast could we
keep this between you and
us all right maybe the cat's out of the
bag
in fact i think i saw him back there
yeah he was in the sink yeah
all right um all right now that i've let
the cat out of the bag
on to other news in the land of unity
twitter shut down
our articles of unity official twitter
account
it was not initially clear exactly what
it was that they thought we had done we
now have more clarity on it
apparently they believe we have been
registering large numbers of phony
accounts for the purpose
of trending we are in the midst of an
internal audit to figure out if there's
anything we need to know
now i should say unity 2020 is an
all-volunteer organization everyone
including me is a volunteer and it is a
vast organization
so is it possible somebody has engaged
in some behavior deep down in the
the depths of unity 2020 i can't say but
we are checking to see if there's
anything that we don't know but we
believe we stand accused of things that
we did not do
and i will say that um irrespective of
what has happened
the behavior on the part of twitter is
egregious
in the sense that uh not only did they
uh suspend our official uh account
but they have also instituted a policy
where if you attempt to uh to
tweet a link to our official website
your tweet does not go through and you
are given one of many errors it's a very
remarkable
behavior now it is possible that that
behavior has been reversed but
for a long period of time anyone who
tried it from anywhere
discovered exactly the same thing which
was that it was not allowed to tweet
links to our website so things are afoot
where this actually comes from is a very
difficult to say
and i will say that after we know uh
what has taken place inside the
organization we will do a deeper dive on
this topic and figure out
what the implications are but for the
moment i have the sense that we may have
caught the attention of goliath and
goliath may be fighting back
it's never a safe place to be no no
on the other hand i wouldn't bet on
goliath i hope not
let's let's all bet against goliath all
right
um there are four broad topics that i'd
like us to talk about today
uh uh many of them focused on the scene
in our in our hometown home state now
but they speak to
to truths that are happening elsewhere
and uh
the topics as i have sort of sound bited
them are and i don't you know i don't
usually use language like this
um but the mayor of portland ted wheeler
wheeler's being a dumbass okay so that's
one that's where we're going to start
lewis and clark college which is a
private liberal arts college in
southwest portland is going full woke
ohsu oregon health and sciences
university which
has a world-class hospital associated
with it is has shut down a coveted study
for not being appropriately inclusive
and we're going to talk a little bit
about why looting is so awesome
yeah so let's start with wheeler all
right um
he proudly publicized a letter refusing
help from federal officers to address
the violence in
portland zack if you would show my
screen here
this is his tweet he says today i sent
this is from 23 hours ago
so from yesterday today i sent this
letter via email to realdonaldtrump
declining his recurring offer to aid
portland by sending federal enforcement
to the city
and the letter reads begins dear
president trump
yet again you said you offered to aid
portland by sending in federal law
enforcement to our city
on behalf of the city of portland no
thanks we don't need your politics of
division and demagoguery
portlanders are onto you et cetera et
cetera et cetera
so uh as one commenter noted uh in
response to this this is zayed jalani
it's like wheeler is a double agent for
trump he's certainly
he's certainly acting as if to promote
uh the likelihood that trump will get
reelected
given given what actually those of us
who are here
know to be true which is in part and
we've talked about this many times
already on on the podcast portland is
being used
as a as a bludgeon on both sides by the
mainstream media to
to a large extent it's just it's either
not being covered at all by the
mainstream media on the left
um or when it is it's at those moments
when there is a far-right presence in
the streets as well
and then they can truth truthfully claim
uh that extremists on both sides
had it out as happened a week ago
um today i think it was um and of course
on the right the mainstream media
insofar as
um it exists outside of fox but fox
included
um talks about the the exact opposite it
only talks about the violence
um and and never never discusses any
possible legitimacy to
uh to the protests uh that we're seeing
but
the fact is downtown portland is
during the day looks like
a former city i don't i don't like the
term war zone because i think that that
evokes something
very particular that i'm not sure i know
enough about all of the intricacies of
to
to say a lot about but um
at the end of may just as many
businesses downtown were
preparing to open up after months of
covet lockdowns
the protests started the violence began
at a regular moment every night shortly
thereafter and have
and those riots have happened every
single night uninterrupted for
i think it's more than 90 days i believe
there has been one interruption there's
been one interruption there's been one
interruption
uh after the after the feds were pulled
after governor brown
negotiated two nights ago
um there was one night and there was
speculation about what it might be and
it turns out that what we're going to
talk about soon here
may have something to do with the actual
reasoning but i'm not sure we know
okay uh so uh i mean as
as viewers regular viewers of this
podcast will be well aware
um stores are vandalized uh many have
been boarded up
um and closed since then there's been
nightly violence
homeless encampments are spreading even
further than they were previously i mean
all of the west coast cities
have had a problem with homelessness um
for a very
long time um there's garbage in the
streets there's increasingly human feces
in the streets and not just that being
thrown by
idiot rioters but actually it's just
it's just
literally becoming a cesspool and it
makes a person wonder how anyone who
calls himself a leader
uh could possibly let this happen to his
city this is this is
a beautiful city it's been it's been
beautiful
open to everyone replete with culinary
and cultural and nature experiences and
this is just a disaster
so we see in the oregonian
on august 26 business owners reporting
being ever more frustrated
on august 27th we see i guess you could
put this up very briefly
um we see a report
that uh 70 the portland business
alliance and 70 other business and civic
leaders
were on the phone with mayor wheeler on
thursday morning to discuss his plan to
revive downtown
um in which one of the things in this
piece is wheeler also said wednesday
let's see wheeler also said wednesday
that ending nightly violence and getting
our community back on its feet would be
a major priority for the city and
something he believed was a necessary
prerequisite to the economic recovery of
downtown
well them's easy words there's no
evidence that he's doing anything
anything to that end and then well
in fact he is doing exactly the opposite
he is treating
the knightly riots as
if they have some legitimacy and you
said earlier the protests
might have some legitimacy i want to be
very careful the anger that fuels the
protests yes
comes from a legitimate place i don't
think these protests have any legitimacy
anymore they have
lost yes they have lost any legitimacy
they might once have had
by um not doing anything to stem the
violence that arises from the violence
is predictable
and that means that everybody who signs
up even the people who aren't being
violent
are signing up for something that leads
to violence that's the
responsibility is on them some people
are flocking there in part
because it's an excuse for a street
party there's no other place to do it
so but mayor wheeler's behavior i'm just
guessing here i've been very busy with
unity stuff
am i right that his behavior has made
the protesters
enthusiastic about mayor wheeler himself
that they are very pleased with his
behavior
they love him he's he's completely on
their side wait no
let's see where have we seen this before
like every time this happens yes at
evergreen
yes every place else when you have a
weak leader who pretends
to be on the side of the protesters they
still aren't going to love you
they still don't they're never going to
love you ted so how about stand up to
them and stop this so zack
um show my screen here we have oops
um you don't have to um i don't think
you need to
um this is just you know this is video
of protesters going into the lobby of
uh wheeler's condo presumably it says
apartment i doubt he's a renter but if
he's lucky maybe he is
in which they demand that he resign
abolish the police by 2022 with no tech
or private replacement
and a lot saved resources to buy pocket
communities and city services
so you know another classic move from
the playbook of
i'm sorry but just witless protesters
you can't have both of those things
you can't both resign and abolish the
police by 2022
and finally they're saying it they're
actually saying it abolish not defund
abolish the police by 2022 with no tech
or private replacement
yeah wow you know what he should say in
response to this
no yeah uh thank you but no
get out of my building stop it
in every regard and yes i am sending in
reinforcements
and no we are not going to be violent
with you unless you force our hand
yeah it's uh i mean it's totally
predictable
and the fact is here's here's what
wheeler is clearly missing
he um has a vast population of people
who now have every right to fear that
this
is going to come into their
neighborhoods and do who knows what
they've been
harassing people shining bright lights
into their windows cursing at them
demanding that they come out into the
streets now they're in wheeler's own
building
right so portlanders have a very real
reason to
fear that this nightly riot phenomenon
will come
directly to them at home right
that means there will be an awful large
fraction of the population of portland
that would be grateful to have this
reigned in
finally it has no legitimacy it is it is
announcing the fact that it is uh
vile and irresponsible literally we have
people throwing
feces at police officers so
there would clearly be a great deal of
support if he would just behave like a
mayor
now will they say that he's part of a
fascist crackdown
if he actually has the police do their
job and arrest law breakers
takes them to jail of course they will
totally predictable on the other hand
will a large fraction of the population
of portland breathe a sigh of relief
that finally governance is doing what it
is supposed to do
what society depends on it doing of
course there would be and because he
only hears the vocal part
yeah right the vocal part is the tantrum
right this is a tantrum and and he is
responding to it
because the adults are being quiet
waiting for him to do his job and the
fact is
do your job and the adults will support
it it's guaranteed
yeah so he's supposed to be the adult
you know when when you elect a mayor
you're
you're electing an adult in part uh to
act and you know this isn't a perfect
analogy a mayor isn't a parent
but what everyone probably has seen
the screaming toddler in the supermarket
who is having a meltdown because they
can't get the thing that they want
and most people have probably also seen
the parent say no
no you can't no you can't and finally
cave
what does that do it results in the
screaming toddler
very very briefly being quiet but what
that toddler has learned
is that tantrums work that is what is
happening here that is bad parenting
that is bad mayorship that is bad
leading in every regard you don't cave
to tantrums you just
you just don't do it and you know it's
not that
anyone will be perfect in this regard
and there are some situations where oh
my god this is exactly the wrong moment
okay
you little brat you little rioters
whatever it is i'm going to have to give
you this thing right now but you can be
damn sure that once we get to a place
where i can
enforce good behavior i am going to do
so fairly and justly and you are going
to learn that this does not pay
why are we letting rioting and looting
and violence pay why would you do that
if you actually care about the city if
you actually care about society if you
actually care about democracy
you don't you're either not thinking it
through
in any way and frankly he's had plenty
of time
or you actually don't care about the
city or society or democracy so which is
it
yeah well okay i guess we'll stay tuned
and see whether the sit-in continues
until mayor wheeler finally abolishes
the police in the hope that that will
finally satisfy the the rioters which of
course it wouldn't
i know i'll feel safer all right
so we have also to talk about
uh lewis and clark college uh which is a
private liberal arts college in
southwest portland uh across the river
from reed so you know we've got a couple
of these elite private colleges
in in portland in which right now as
as we are speaking to you live there is
mandatory training for all new students
taking place
uh here is the description in the
schedule zach if you would um
just pop on and off my screen a little
bit um right now we have
12 15 p.m to four today um
why is oregon so white they ask and then
they say welcome to portland
well that seems like a sort of a mixed
message that from the group race talks
which is organizing this which has been
invited presumably by lewis and clark
to organize this mandatory training so
if you click on the link
at the top of that last page you will
find this
engage for racial justice a lewis and
clark new student orientation workshop
they say that they are going to
concentrate on historical and
contemporary issues of race and racism
in portland
centering black indigenous and people of
color's voices to allow groups that are
traditionally overlooked
in academic and business settings to
feel seen
bottom paragraph here additionally we
want to center further marginalized
voices who may include but are not
limited too
you ready for this oh i am yeah people
with darker complexions or skin tone
queer identified non-binary non-gender
conforming
disabled persons with accents or from
other countries
ethnic minority sick people who
physically express their religious
identity
and more wow wow all right
yeah i mean i know they missed some
but this is this is simultaneously an
attempt to
pretend to be as inclusive as possible
and to actually
and to actually make sure that you can
shut down dissent
by claiming that people don't have
enough points in that progress so-called
progressive stack
of historic oppression and therefore you
have no ground to stand on because you
yourself don't know oppression
okay the organization race talks pdx
which has been presumably hired i know
it has no formal affiliation with lewis
and clark so presumably hired by lewis
and clark college
to run these trainings um has this
helpful quiz
for you to find out what your race talks
iq is zach if you could not show my
screen please
um could could click on that link and
show it so that i can read off my screen
and um
[Music]
actually if if if you can't find it i
can just read off my
my paper notes um
yeah yep so i'm gonna have you uh yeah
there it is
so this is a quiz this is a helpful quiz
that they have um to find out your race
talks iq
uh here's my very helpful summary i
think of their quiz
so number one is are you by poc which is
um
what does bipod stand for uh biracial
indigenous person of color maybe but i'm
not sure that b
stands for biracial black indigenous
uh people of color yes okay so are you a
bipac
well um this question then reveals that
you actually get more
race iq points for being born a certain
way
that's both original sin and uh you know
that's actually that's racism right
there okay
number two do you actively live or
socialize with bipod communities
three have you experienced being the
only person of your ethnicity in the
room on a dozen or more occasions
now these actually make sense to me
these actually seem to me
like decent metrics of whether or not
you
have you have an ability to have some
sense of what it might be like
to be an actual minority in
in a society in a classroom in a
business and while they certainly
aren't going to be the end-all and
be-all in terms of you know
how you you can never know you know as
as we have
living and doing research in madagascar
for instance where very often we were
the only vasa the only white people
in in a whole town for instance or that
people had ever seen
that does change your way of
understanding what it is to be in the
world but the fact is
that our white skin was still a
privilege and was still protective
i'm having none of this none of it none
of it at all because
the idea that the
your iq something that they're
analogizing to
iq about racial issues is going to be
synonymized with some
fact of your experience rules out the
possibility
of somebody who's very insightful having
discovered what you might learn
from being the only person of your
ethnicity
in the room through literature or
imagination or anything else and i'm not
saying i mean i get
so i mean we are getting there i know
but i i get your point
that yes it is useful to have had that
experience but the thing is
i mean the reason i think i'm
emotionally responding to this
is so this is this is your first time
seeing it if you synonymize
smarts with well have you taken this
class and did you do well have you taken
that class and did you do well
then the answer is all of those of us
for whom school didn't work are just
sort of stupid by definition and my
feeling is no some of us did not end up
stupid by definition and that tells you
a lot about school
and it's non-essential nature so my
point would be look
i want people to understand what it
means to be the only person of your
ethnicity in the room and if you haven't
had the experience
then you need to spend some time
imagining it but i don't want to be told
that if you haven't had that experience
you couldn't possibly know
that's garbage i i agree
and you know i think if i if i'm trying
to steal man this
movement and it's really hard to steal
man this quiz and really the only two
points on this that i think are are
stated well at all are that number two
and three
uh then i will say this is a
this is a feature of being um
of potentially being able to have some
insight into what it is
uh to have been you know born born black
born of an ethnicity that has not only
been a minority and oppressed throughout
the history of the west
but frankly even when we go for instance
to madagascar the fact that we may be
the only white people that people have
ever seen
doesn't change the fact that we a come
and we can at any moment
leave so we can leave our minority
status but we are also
because in the case of madagascar as the
french who came in and colonized
we are still wearing this sort of mask
of of power so i you know
i i'm trying to steal man the part of
this that actually makes sense
and you know the rest of these let's
just let's just move on here
zach i'd love for you to continue to
show this uh four and five are
let's see my cat's sitting on my notes
now um have you read more than 10
african-american authors
have you read more than 10 authors from
the african diaspora
so these numbers you know 10. who cares
about 10
and you know wouldn't reading four books
by tony morrison um
be you know pretty powerful actually
she's extraordinary i read a ton of her
work in
in high school actually and um was was
really deeply affected by it and does
that only count as one point here you
know so this is this kind of like
pseudo-numerate enumerate garbage um
and you know why is it so important that
you both read
a lot of african-american and a lot of
authors from the african diaspora
you know put that aside there is some
value and you alluded to this
right in your in your emotional response
like actually there are a lot of ways
to gain to gain knowledge of what it is
to be
living in someone else's skin right
let's move on now
to six and seven six can you discuss the
relationship between affirmative action
bipoc non-binary stacking order and
white centering
seven do you understand the
intersectionality between bypoc
and lgbtqia2s
first i don't know what ia2s stand for
q apparently means uh both queer and
questioning
and those last two are not only a bunch
of gobbledygook
you know postmodern garbage language
but they also are pointing out this this
tie
again between this movement that says
it's about race and says it's about
focusing centering black people so that
everyone can understand
what that lived experience is and what
the history of oppression has been
and making sure it doesn't move into the
future with
with trans issues and that frankly has
no place here but
we've pointed out again and again and
again that it's on the black lives
matter webpage
it's all over the rhetoric of this
movement which should make those people
who think
this is this movement is what it says it
is think again
finally eight have you joined a social
justice organization for black people or
advocated openly for black people at
work
socially or with a governmental agency
suggesting that
if you are not an activist in the way
that we say you need to be
you have low race iq so this is exactly
the same thing that they are doing
on on the streets and in classrooms and
everywhere else and
we see again and again that people who
would end up with a high score
on that quiz if they arrive at a
conclusion that is different from this
movement
have their perspectives dismissed so
that's right and if you don't if you
don't prioritize race in your daily life
in the same way that we do you're not a
good person you have low race iq
you need to be schooled you need to be
shamed right and so
anyway i i just that
that exercise is designed to
flatter the people who created it
and those who think like them and it is
designed to allow the exclusion of
everybody else right are we to
understand you know
for one thing uh suppose you
because you were disadvantaged didn't
acquire literacy
right now we're gonna decide that you're
race
stupid because you didn't read
books maybe you acquired that
information somewhere else maybe
you know who knows what the
possibilities are but the idea
that a this is something that is
formulaic
and that your you know your empathic
capacity isn't an essential component in
your ability to infer
from the literature you've read from the
experiences you've had what they
actually mean about somebody else's
situation is missing from that so
anyway i find the entire thing it's like
one of these
little you know tests that a
grade schooler would set up in order to
define who gets to be in their club
right and the test is designed so that
only people that they want in the club
will actually pass it and it's like okay
i'm not playing that goddamn game yeah
it actually that's that's
i think very apt it is like a grade
school test
of are you in or are you out um it also
reminds me of
um the kinds of quizzes that show up in
magazines for teen girls and you know
the fact that teen vogue has
like who even though that who even knew
that teen vogue existed but like somehow
it's been captured
and is being weaponized as part of this
woke movement and
you know encouraging not just fealty to
black lives matter but actually things
like sex work for girls like
it's it's disgusting and reprehensible
the way that it's gone but these kinds
of quizzes
that um have long been used to
basically create lack of confidence
and in in teenage girls and make them
wonder if they're good enough or pretty
enough
or are going to be liked enough by boys
um
this is this is exactly that sort of
thing like are you
do you belong are you with us or are you
against us
it's more this us versus them there's
good people there's bad people
it's this it's you know it's the comic
bookification of
the us but it's also like the teen
magazine occasion
if you will of of the us yeah and it's
um if you think about i mean uh
push pull a push-pull is a poll that its
purpose is not actually to get any
information the purpose is to manipulate
your
belief system on the basis of the
questions that you're being asked which
shift what you think is
is actually the case um in this case the
fact that
you know you of course want a high race
iq don't you
um and uh so you know geez have i read
10
black authors yeah you know i'm counting
on your fingers maybe i don't
quite don't quite get there i almost
went and looked at my bookshelf honestly
i almost went and looked at my bookshelf
this is pushing you and the thing is
anybody who comes up
feeling a little bit insecure about
their race iq
is going to end up feeling like well i
certainly have to behave as if i have a
high race iq
so that i don't get discovered to have a
low one anyway this this is just pure
childish manipulative garbage and the
fact is
meet people talk to them listen to what
they have to say
your superficial prejudices will
evaporate you'll discover
that you know people are complex and
once you have done that you will have
some basis to understand
all of the things that we're uh we're
forced to grapple with
um but if you're gonna you know pat
yourself on the back for passing some
stupid quiz
or start behaving in you know geez how
can i raise my
race iq i guess i'm supposed to go find
a person of color that i can advocate
for
at work you know and then you're gonna
find potentially somebody
who's playing the victim and you'll just
advocate for him so you can boost your
little score and go back and take the
test again and
anyway so at best i mean even if you
found someone who's who's honorable it's
going to promote tokenism
which which no one wants to be a token
of any movement no no
good faith person wants to be a token of
any movement and with regard to oh
i got to be able to prove that i
actually you know read tony morrison and
alice walker and you know all of these
people
um and so well isn't that going to
encourage exactly the kind of academic
gaming that we already have it's going
to it's like going to promote cliff's
notes versions of these books so that
you can have exactly the quote that you
need
in order to demonstrate that you're
really well familiar with the over these
african-american authors which no that's
not the point
you need to sit in actually i mean this
this is the part of lived experience
that does make sense right like what
is it to live like other people this is
why travel is so valuable this is why
literature is so valuable and other
narrative
and it's not to be able to get a good
pull quote that makes you look like
you've
actually experienced something no you
actually there's there's no cheating
this
really if you really are trying to
understand what it's like
um to be like other people you need to
as as you just said brett
talk to them live with them go
go be in the places where they are
uh you know eat their food listen to
their music you know
engage with other cultures honorably
and with respect and with the
understanding that we are all
actually individual human beings with
with faults and with some glory some of
which is hidden some of which isn't
and if you will take the time to try to
discover it you can do so
i would say um generosity of spirit
and openness of mind are the tools you
need
and everything else is a matter of
exposure um
yeah and i i'm going
to get over my uh reaction to this
gamification of this whole thing became
the whole thing has become a game yes it
has become a game and we're going to
tear civilization apart over that game
and uh it's going to be the most um
spectacular and
needless loss in human history yeah
that's right okay uh
let's switch for the moment to talking
about
this um shutdown by oregon health
sciences university ohsu
of a big cobia 19 study uh so this
here uh zach you can show this just very
briefly this is in again in the
oregonian on august 27th
ohsu ends massive coronavirus study
because it underrepresented minorities
university says uh this is about a key
to oregon study which have been
projected to cost 24 million dollars
every year
was to track a hundred thousand people's
coronavirus symptoms
and when it was announced in may
governor kate brown called the program a
game changer
sounds great um quote one of its
original goals was to make sure people
of color signed up to participate but
that did not happen
follow the link in that article
and find this from ohsu this is no
longer the oregonian this is ohsu's
actual
news release from august 27th as well
ohsu ends covet 19 study supports
ongoing conversations between black
indigenous and people of color
decolonizing research and data council
and governor's office
to better understand disproportionate
impacts of the virus within communities
of color and urban-based indians and
tribes
so so yeah fairfax here didn't like that
last bit
um the claim is and it's a claim and
this is this is the point here the claim
is that there are disproportionate
impacts of
the virus okay paragraph
three of this good lord cat
paragraph three of this news release
from ohsu reads
specifically covet 19 has intensified
the profound and disproportionately
adverse public health impacts that have
long harmed
harmed black indigenous and people of
color as well as other historically
disadvantaged populations including but
not limited to
latin x and hispanic asian and pacific
islanders
it is critical that the state improve
its understanding of covet 19 prevalence
by centering research on the communities
most affected okay
this is why they have um they have
shut down this this major study that
appeared to actually be doing some
some good because because
they say they did not manage to attract
enough bypoc people of color black
indigenous people
to the study and therefore they were not
able to keep track of those once again
the claims are
um sorry i'm looking
the claims are that those people suffer
disproportionate impacts
and uh that they are the communities
most affected those are direct
quotations from the ohsu news release
we find again in that in that first
article i showed you quote the program's
failure is a major hit to oregon's
effort to monitor study and ultimately
curb the pandemic
the pandemic has affected black people
american indians and pacific islanders
particularly hard with case rates many
times higher than those for whites
with a link okay let's follow
the link that they are giving to support
the claim they just made okay
so this is a fairly long um a long
report and here i gotta move you kitty
cat
um and it's it's pretty good
it's published again august 26th so the
day before
um this this uh gets shut down
there's a whole lot here a whole lot of
uh
a whole lot of numbers and at first you
just gotta wonder where
is the evidence what are they talking
about where is the evidence
so take me off this for a moment zach so
i can just i don't make people
dizzy by scrolling down to get to table
three
nope that's age group table three is
uh the only thing that i can see from
this that actually shows
um that actually seems to
address the point that is made um that
this is being linked to so this is table
three for those just listening
severity and rates of covert 19 by race
so if you look at the fourth column
cases per thousand
you see that in fact black american
indian and alaska native
and pacific islander populations indeed
have a higher case rate
um of over a thousand or in the case of
pacific islander
almost three thousand this is per 100
sorry per 100 000
um for those demographics whereas white
and
asian um uh people have uh cases for a
hundred thousand of 281
and 393 respectively okay so
um that is certainly one measure
of the effect of um
of how much people are being affected by
this virus right um and we know of
course that focusing on severe symptoms
now and deaths is a thin metric and
we've been pushing against
um case focusing on case fatality rate
for instance and just deaths
for a while now because we know that
there are lingering health effects for
people who've had copenhagen
and we can therefore suspect we are
predicting that there may be very
long-term effects
from this disease so i do not in any way
mean to minimize
people who have had cases that weren't
severe
however let us look at the two other
measures
on the screen zack if you would show
that again please
on this table of uh of the effects of
covid
percent hospitalized and case fatality
rate percent hospitalized
um for whites blacks asians american
indians etc is
all basically the same they aren't
giving us raw numbers
or maybe i actually could maybe we could
even do a
chi-square with this um but those those
numbers look all
pretty similar right i mean you know
blacks
are um hospitalized at slightly lower
rates than whites and nations and
american indians but i really don't
think in pacific islanders but i really
doubt that that's in any way significant
um so those numbers basically look the
same but if you go and so by that metric
if you're looking at percent
hospitalized you would say actually none
of the demographics
if we if we're looking at demographics
by race are more or less affected
which is a direct i should point out
here there's one potential confound
which i think you're about to rule out
in your final category here but one
thing hospitalization rates
could have something to do for with
access to services
could be yes yes that a disproportionate
if if blacks were disproportionately
affected they didn't show up in the
hospitalization rate
because for whatever reason they didn't
go to the hospital and maybe because we
know there's a correlation with class
and so you know people who are poorer
whether or not it's because they are
also more likely to be black or less
likely to go to the hospital even when
they need it
we would then predict that the case
fatality rate would be
higher again that the cases per 100 000
and the case fatality rate
would be comparable um even if
hospitalization rate wasn't
but when in fact we see in this final
column
of exactly the table that is linked to
as evidence
that black american indian pacific
islanders in oregon are being
disproportionately affected by coven 19
is that the case fatality rate for
whites and asians
is two to three times higher than it is
for blacks
and for american indians and for pacific
islanders
so it's more than double so how is it
that they can claim with a straight face
and literally cancel a
study a long-term study that actually
was
maybe going to do some good on the basis
that it was not
successfully encouraging enough people
of color to come and be participants in
it because those people are inherently
the most affected by this crisis their
very data show
that they had to pick and choose they
had to cherry-pick the metric that they
used in order to make that point they
had to cherry-pick
this is not how an a university with
health and science in its name this is
ohsu
this is the biggest most premiere uh
hospital and health and and university
by many metrics in
the state of oregon what are they doing
this doesn't look like science this
doesn't look like math
this doesn't look like healthcare it
looks like bad science it looks like
verification of science and so that's
the thing cherry picking is the method
for verifications where they look and
you know we saw this
um across the board in the evergreen
fiasco where
a vast amount of data existed and it was
cherry-picked in order to suggest a very
particular narrative about
um people of color being left behind by
evergreen when the data actually
frequently reflected exactly the
opposite
exactly that the college was doing well
by its students of color so
anyway cherry picking is the hallmark
of verificationism which is the hallmark
of a dishonest attempt
to advance a narrative above the facts
yeah and in this case the thing that i
find most striking about it
is that it's not as if the study was
accidentally constructed to exclude you
know
the way many medical studies have
excluded women you know
because men are a convenient study group
maybe there's bias that goes into
choosing men but the point is
you know you can have studies like this
that are uh
non-representative for some reason but
in this case they specifically went out
of their way to recruit
uh bypoc people they apparently failed
to attract sufficient numbers
for the group that is claiming they
didn't detect sufficient numbers right
which doesn't suggest that the study
discriminated against these people it
suggested these people discriminated
against the study and
the idea that you should not collect
data
right because people who you tried to
include
didn't end up included for whatever
reason
is preposterous because you know the
fact that that's that's shut down stem
right there that's successful shutdown
stem
they win it's successful everyone
everything they think they win but they
lose too and so do all the rest
right so the fact is though the thing
that's hard to wrap your mind around
here
is people are actually going to die for
lack of data yep right people are
actually going to contract this disease
and they're going to die because the
data is not going to properly inform
them about the symptoms that arise
in this which you know frankly the
symptoms if you're following something
that tells you what these symptoms are
like
are frightening enough to spook you into
being very careful about this disease
knowing what those symptoms are is going
to be
key to protecting yourself and how they
unfold you know you and i have been
advocating
now for more than 40 live streams for
the collection of large-scale data on
the progression of the disease so that
we understand something
about how it works so yes this is shut
down stem and the result is going to be
humans are going to die that's right
that's what happens when you shut down
stem
we need better stem we need
hypothesis-driven research to once again
become
the thing that people are doing when
they say they're doing science
but shut down stem people will die
that's what will happen
people will die and you won't know their
names which is going to make it easy to
ignore
right you won't know which people died
because of the lack of of this data
that's right so is the nature such as
the nature of complex systems yeah
yeah absolutely so just one more thing
from this uh from this document before
we um
go into talking about why looting is so
awesome and everyone should engage in it
um table one which is just two tables up
from the one i just
showed you is severity and rates of code
with 19 by sex
oh because we're in yeah okay so
severity and rates of code 19 by sex
this is not a point uh that is being uh
made particularly in in the media at
this point although we talked about it
early on in our first
17 or 18 live streams when we were
talking a lot about kovid
which is that men are are men are
disproportionately more likely
to die from coven and here we have
again actually women having slightly
more cases per hundred thousand again i
suspect that that's not
a statistically significant difference
558 559 for
men versus 607 for women could be but
um and you know curious interesting that
that's the case
um but then you have a hospitalization
rate
of almost 9 for men 7.3 for women
and a case fatality rate of 2 for men
and 1.4
for women but that's not what we're
supposed to talk about
because no one is allowed to be talking
about disproportionate effects on men
right now
um and oh by the way non-binary unless
these people are actually intersex
i'm sorry you're messing with data and
science and you're not allowed to do
that
intersex is real but non-binary because
you don't really feel like a man or a
woman no you shouldn't be allowed to do
that i don't know why they let those
those and there's descriptions in here
there's no reason to break that data
out here other than to virtue signal
right no that's that's right
yeah so um interesting
that at a moment when the study is being
shut down
for um a reason that has been
cherry-picked
with regard to racial outcomes there's
also exactly
no mention of the clear trend
to that this that this disease impacts
men more severely
than women so there's that all right
so i have one oh go ahead uh yeah i'm
just i'm eager to talk about looting
yes well before we do that i wanted to
at the i only briefly perused this i had
a very scary moment
zach could you put up the uh the beach
um so i saw a headline that stopped me
in my
tracks um indicating
let's see oregon epidemiologist
beach party may be linked to more than
300 cases of
covid19 and i saw that and i thought oh
my god
and now in fact if this were true that
connects to this
um so you you go on but what i was gonna
say is
the idea that a beach party caused a
large number of cases was very
frightening because you and i have been
telling people for a long time we've
been telling them two things
one apparently outdoors is very very
safe
especially during the day we've also
been telling them we predict if we are
not careful outdoors that that will
change
because the virus apparently doesn't
know how to get transmitted outdoors but
it would be an advantage if it could
and so we need to be very vigilant
outside yeah and we need to wait
for the possibility of the virus
changing and i thought maybe it's here
okay but i mean if you read just this
first sentence in this in this article
which i hadn't seen before now and i can
barely see because of where it's
oriented
it says this summer 20 friends rented a
beach house on the oregon coast for a
three days celebration
so these aren't people hanging out on
the beach apparently four of them showed
up
sick right and the 300 number is
downstream cases as they fanned out from
their beach gathering but
my point is a the broadcasting of ideas
like oh a bunch of people got sick at a
beach party
is destructive because it means that
they can't do exactly the thing that
they should do which is while the sun is
still
shining in the northern hemisphere they
should go out and take advantage of it
yes they should not be reckless but they
should they should uh
drink in the sun as much as they can
drinking the feeling of normalcy that
you get and we've been doing a better
and better job of this
of late but if we tell them oh my god
you're going to get sick at a beach
party
then people are going to you know
withdraw indoors and
winter is going to be even worse so i
just wanted to call
attention to that um that spectacular
failure of
um titling that article
and the sloppy nature of the thinking
which we still see
outdoors as people are hyper vigilant
where they don't need to be
where they frown on those who are taking
advantage of the
safety of the environment etc i will say
that since you know we've been out on
on the river um exploring um
paddle sports uh the last several days
and that
feels like normalcy you don't you know
people
outside enjoying being in the water um
they're it it it almost looks
like a normal year and it feels like it
certain places and
well worth it it may not be the water
you may not have access to water
like this we're lucky in portland that
we do the willamette is a beautiful
beautiful river but something in your
area
may look like this where people have
figured out how to carve out a patch of
normalcy
in all of the strangeness and just
simply
going someplace where you can forget for
five minutes that kovid's even going on
is probably just important to feeling
like
you know this isn't just some nightmare
that never ends absolutely
uh let me just before we talk about
looting and which i know we're both
eager to do
um actually so i showed you table three
and i showed you table one
um but here's table two from the same
document severity and rates of coping 19
by age group so we showed you race and
we showed you sex here's age group
interesting because let's start over at
the right hand column case fatality rate
for
um excuse me people through the age of
39 is
literally showing up a zero and it's not
zero deaths but it's such a low
percentage that's showing up a zero
climbs to zero point two percent for
forty to forty nine point
eight for the next decade three point
four
um eight point nine percent cfr case
fatality rate for 70 79
and then for 80 plus it's 23.2 so that's
totally in keeping with what we've been
hearing from the beginning actually
that's one of the few things about this
disease that we have
that has not changed right early on it
was thought that
young people couldn't get it and you
know basically if you were really you
really couldn't get it at all
and that the effects were were null we
now know that both of those things are
not true and we don't know what all the
effects might be
but very telling in light of your uh
beach house
um contagion uh headline that you just
showed but
uh that we have over in cases per
hundred thousand
um the highest the age group with the
highest number of cases per hundred
thousand
is twenty year olds um and then it's the
next highest
is 30 to 39 year olds and so to me what
that says
is um this is this this pandemic
um has been really hard on everyone
lockdowns are rough
and that some number of people in you
know in oregon which is in the northern
hemisphere and so you know summer is
is is happening and sometimes people are
just saying no way i'm not going to do
it i am going to socialize
and sure enough uh you're they're
getting sick at a higher level that's a
hypothesis
um but it's a hypothesis is consistent
with what you just showed
about the the beach house yeah
absolutely
and you know if we were clear and
consistent we could say you know
socialize outdoors do it at a distance
don't spend five minutes talking face to
face with somebody keep your
you know either be far apart and if you
have to talk close up
make it brief wear a mask you know as
you start a conversation with somebody
pull a mask up there's lots of ways to
do it and if you want to get away
together try camping
yeah yeah don't try not sharing an hvac
system with a bunch of people some of
whom may be sick already
totally um yeah it's a it's really
important that we figure out how to
thread the needle and you know bad data
and rotten testing aren't helping
no they're not they're really they're
really quite a disaster but i would also
say if you can go back to that
chart strongly implied
by that distribution of data
is something that is also consistent
with the pattern that you will discover
if you
uh look at the you know for example the
subreddit of infected covet infected
people
and the what they call long haulers
people who've had it for months and it
doesn't are still experiencing symptoms
yeah they're cured but it
doesn't the symptoms keep recurring on
them or they think they're cured
um but that this is having
a destructive effect on the body the
closer you are to death by virtue of
your age the more likely it is to push
you
over that line right and so yeah you get
very low case fatality rates for young
people that does not mean
no damage what it means is you probably
had 10 years knocked off the
end of your life which you won't realize
until you begin to get old enough that
those
uh maladies show up earlier than they
should or earlier than they would
and so we ought to be behaving like
there's a menace out there
that can if you are careless about it
knock 10 or 20
years off your life all right if you
behaved that way
then you would be properly encoding this
if you think well
i'm young if i get it i'll probably get
better so i'm going to roll the dice
because there's a lot going on and i
don't like
being locked down a you're going to give
it to people who
are old enough that it may kill them and
b you are going to rob yourself in the
future
and if you get hit by a bus maybe you
get away with it but if you don't get
hit by a bus you're probably going to be
paying the cost
down the line and you may even be paying
the cost six months down the line a year
down the line
you know brain fog circulatory damage
all of these things this is this is
nothing to mess around with
yeah it's not all right
on to looting not we're not going to
do any looting i'm not going to promise
that i mean once you once you hear about
how awesome it is and important it is
i think you may change your mind i'm not
gonna do any loading okay fair enough
i really i actually seriously wish that
people couldn't make this stuff up
because
um you know it's it's really it's cliche
to say you can't make this stuff up but
that's what people are doing people are
making [ __ ] up
and publishing it and then they're
getting interviewed by npr
and npr and other outlets are taking
this seriously and it's becoming
mainstream
and it's it's not nonsense it's not
garbage it is
it is destructive i don't i don't even
have the words
i don't even know what it is it's it's
just destructive
awful i it this borders on evil and
that's not a word i use very much
so here we have um just a minute zach
before you show it an npr
interview with an author of a recently
published book
called i kid you not in defense of
looting
so here we go um
this is um i'm just going to read a
couple of
a couple of a couple of these we'll talk
about and then i want to finish with
what she begins with
so it's this author i'll get to vicky
osterwheel
probably mispronouncing her name um
can you talk about rooting rooting
looting as a tactic
is the question oh sorry i'm looking for
it i should have had you pull this up
zach
um here we go can you talk about a
rioting as a tactic
what are the reasons people deploy it as
a strategy
so she's not just advocating looting
she's advocating for writing as well
she says it does a number of important
things writing does it gets people what
they need for free immediately
which means that they are capable of
living and reproducing their lives
without having to rely on jobs or a wage
which during covet times is widely
unreliable or particularly in these
communities is often not available
or it comes at great risk that's
looting's most basic tactical powers of
political mode of action
it also attacks the very way in which
food and things are distributed
it attacks the idea of property and it
attacks the idea that in order for
someone to have a roof over their head
or have a meal ticket
they have to work for a boss in order to
buy things people just like them
somewhere else in the world had to make
under the same conditions
it points to the way in which that's
unjust and for the reason
the world is organized that way
obviously is for the profit of the
people who own the stores and the
factories
so you get to the heart of that property
relation and demonstrate that without
police and without state oppression
we can have things for free are we
are we being punked i can't
i did i did it without laughing you did
but now you are laughing
oh my god yeah it attacks
the idea that in order for someone to
have a roof over the head
oh yeah i even find the most idiotic
stuff in here it's unbelievable
we can just have things for free if we
get rid of the police
and state oppression because how dare
you want to buy something that was made
by someone somewhere else
i just want it for free wait how does
that thing come to
i right what process produces that thing
and why it is so incoherent in every
regard you had some things to say and i
have some more
oh it is no end of things to say i just
i just feel
like um we are being punked
and whatever advanced civilization is
punching us i wish they would stop i
mean maybe they have a lesson to teach
us and they're going to come down in
their ships and they're going to let us
know what that lesson is and we're all
going to
have a big laugh and then we're going to
go to actually governing the planet
properly
do you remember actually during during
the evergreen debacle
one of the chief instigators really
turns out to have been a truly bad actor
but someone who
i had known beforehand uh to be quite
smart
naimolao who one of her things
was performance art and i
said to you at some point early on i
said is it at all possible
that naima is going to show up on some
stage and take a bow
and say i have now shown you what is
possible
i have shown you how i can get a whole
bunch of people to witnessly follow an
insane movement
and now you know and now you two should
wake up
to the the sheep that you are and
actually
uh try to do some good in the world
rather than spouting off rhetoric
now of course she didn't do that instead
she took the college for a bunch of
money and went off to do whatever the
hell she is doing now so you know
alas she was not playing a giant
performance art uh
hoax on us but wouldn't that be
wonderful
wouldn't wouldn't that be wonderful if
we were being punked here and they were
about to reveal it
should be the next stanley milgram yeah
exactly it would have been so powerful
actually
yeah but i mean i i don't even like
hearing you say this because
the the role she played was so toxic and
having to just monstrously maintain
even just as a formal possibility that
maybe she was actually on the right side
all along because
um oh it's clear that she wasn't at this
point but you know in the early days
even after she decided that i was a
racist and all the other white women
needed to come and collect my ass and
all of this
i thought it's possible maybe i hope no
yeah
yeah no that was wishful thinking of the
highest order yeah
um okay so let's see another uh
another thing from here during so this
uh
show my screen again zach if you would
during recent riots the interviewer from
npr says
a sentiment i heard a lot was that
looters in cities like minneapolis were
hurting their own cause by destroying
small businesses in their own
neighborhoods
stores owned by immigrants and people of
color what would you say to people who
make that argument
the um the answer
is in part it's long so i'm just going
to read part of it
looters and riders don't attack private
homes they don't attack community
centers
in minneapolis there was a small
independent bookstore that was untouched
all the blocks of reddit were basically
looted or even leveled burned down and
that story just remained untouched
through weeks of rioting
to say you're attacking your own
community is to say to rioters you don't
know what you're doing
but i disagree i think people know they
might have worked in those shops they
might have shopped and been followed
around by security guards by the owner
and it goes on and on and on so
verificationist
and actually giving agency to the people
that many of us would like to say gosh
i hope when you grow up in a few years
you see what
damage what harm you caused and she's
saying no no they know are they doing
the right thing
she's giving them ammunition oh well
no i first of all this has no or very
little implication for the people
actually engaged in this behavior
because the people actually get engaged
in this behavior are motivated by things
other than
uh analysis this is true right i mean
looting in particular
is the you know the system that normally
keeps you from walking out of the store
with the tv is not
functioning so you walk out of the store
with the tv that's what motivates
diluting but a lot of people listen to
npr
well that's the thing is it's not the
people this is not targeted at looters
and rioters
this is targeted at people looking for
an excuse
people who have found themselves
confronted with
this isn't a movement about making the
lives of
of black people better look at the
looting and rioting
right look at all those white kids
attacking the federal building in
downtown portland
you know what do you say to somebody who
says that and the answer is well you
don't say anything because frankly it
doesn't add up as part of a movement
that's trying to make
the lives of black people better it adds
up as something else in portland it's
anarchism is what it
adds up to so you just need to hand them
an argument and the fact is it doesn't
have to be
a true argument it doesn't have to be a
credible argument it just has to be
something
that allows npr listeners to wave a book
at people and say you know what
you're wrong about looting right and the
fact is
like most books it's not going to get
read and so the idea that somebody has
come up with an argument
and you haven't read it therefore until
you do looting is back on the menu of
of honorable things you know okay i get
it
so we need a name for this category so
if this book whatever it's called in
defense of looting
is in this category that you just
described of to be used by ammunition to
shut down the people
who have an argument against you robin
d'angelo's white fragility is certainly
in that category as
is iran candies how to be an anti-racist
and it would be great if we had a clever
name for that category that we should
that we could invoke whenever we see
more
more books more whatevers that belong in
that category because
while certainly white fragility and how
to be an anti-racist also serve
significant other functions that they
are you know they are actually
indoctrination tools
i think this book is less likely to be
that and more likely just to be
something
that you know these you know middle
class liberals who listen to npr
can say oh but don't you see that if you
object to
writing and looting you're actually part
of the problem and you're probably a
white supremacist
yeah the purpose of the book is the
cover yeah right the argument is the
cover the sum total of it
um now i don't know because i haven't
read uh
lindsay and pluck rose yeah i've done it
but i'm wondering if this is not central
to their argument
because it seems to be implied on the
cover of their book i know their book is
full of content because they're both
fastidious about these things and uh so
careful such good thinkers
yeah but anyway i'll be curious whether
or not they do have a name for it
and what that name might be yeah
um okay so just two more two more little
bits from this before we
end for today um what would you say to
people
who are concerned about essential places
like grocery stores or pharmacies being
attacked in those communities
zach you probably want to show this
thank you um
and the author says when it comes to
small business family owned business or
locally owned business
they are no more likely to provide
worker protections they are no more
likely to have to provide good stuff for
the community than big businesses
it's actually a republican myth that has
over the last 20 years really crawled
into even leftist discourse
that the small business owner must be
respected that the small business owner
creates jobs and is part of the
community
that's actually a right-wing myth now
wait a second
didn't the argument above suggest you
don't have to worry about the small
business owners because they're going to
be left alone
yes and then hear the answers so they
don't need to be left-wing i guess you
win either way
you win either way that's the thing with
these arguments and the people who make
them
is they make sure to cover all their
bases completely
by doing end runs around their own
arguments and hoping that you aren't
paying attention even from one paragraph
to the next
yeah yes yeah it's uh it's amazing i
must say when i went down
into downtown portland after the rioting
broke out here
one of the first places i encountered
was an artist's cooperative that had had
its window busted in and people had gone
inside and
um didn't look to me i mean the reason i
was struck by it was that it didn't look
like it looked completely indiscriminate
that you would attack an artist
cooperative in portland at the same time
you're attacking the apple store yeah no
it's
there's no there's no rhyme no reason
and they will keep on telling us that we
aren't looking hard enough for the rhyme
or the reason but no we are
and it's just not there um so one more
one more place to end on uh the very
first question in this interview
uh is for people who haven't read your
book how do you define
looting and i don't actually her
definition isn't that
interesting but the second paragraph of
her answer is
looting is a highly racialized word from
its very inception in the english
language
it's taken from hindi lut which means
goods or spoils and it appears in an
english colonial officer's handbook
on indian vocabulary in the 19th century
okay so zach may i have my screen back
thank you what does that even mean um
the claim as far as i understand it
is that uh english having a word from
another language means that that word is
racialized
that's the claim that's the claim even
when the word is actually still being
used in its original meaning
which i looked it up right of course um
it is
like loot loot so um
i went ahead and did some additional
work for for vicky
the author of this book um and the
author of this truly remarkable thought
that uh
lute is a racialized word in english
language because it in fact borrowed
from the hindi word
loot meaning basically the same thing
meaning loot
meaning loot yes uh so i did some work
for her
free of charge i found a bunch of other
highly racialized words in english all
from hindi or urdu
closely related english languages in
india that provided english so many
important words i mean racist tropes
this took me a long time though
i went um i want actually full props for
my ability to google
this phrase list of hindi or urdu words
in english
and for clicking on the wikipedia
article that popped up at the top of the
list so here we go
here are some other words that must be
highly racialized given her
analysis of why loot is highly
racialized avatar
bandana bungalow cheetah
cot juggernaut jungle
pundit pajamas shampoo
typhoon and veranda
so that's sorry guys those
like frankly the vast vast vast majority
of words in english are now racialized
and you should be really careful using
them
um they're all racist we don't have to
stop there of course i think we have to
abandon all words that aren't
indo-european or maybe germanic in
origin algebra certainly that's from the
arabic
in fact man english has a lot of words
from the arabic let's just take
a few that begin with c just c candy
caravan
chemistry cipher from which decipher
comes coffee
cotton crimson they're all racialized
all of them all right now i think i know
where this
goes right the words
are racialized that's bad
so bad we shouldn't use words right
which would leave us in silence which is
violence which is good because rioting
is good because it redistributes goods
in a fair way
did i get it yes if she floats she's a
witch
yes i'm wondering if my if my uh race iq
has been amply demonstrated by that bit
of
bending over you saw the quiz man you
didn't do anything to amplify your race
iq with that little bit of rhetoric no
way no
all right well i'm gonna go read some
books that will
raise it somehow yeah i recommend how to
be an anti-racist
um all right i will start with uh ibram
candies how to be an anti-racist and i
will come back to you uh
i can't say non-racist because that's
not even possible i guess i will just be
less racist
yeah that's that's what we are all
aspiring to in this world
um i think that that's what i've got for
today
all right well on that ironic note
uh let's see i guess we have some
announcements and then we'll take our
pause
yeah so we'll take 15 minutes as we do
and answer when we come back
answer your questions on superchat from
this hour and then from the next hour
tomorrow we will have our private q a
on at 11 a.m which is accessible on my
patreon
you can access the private discord
server um as
at either of our patreons and uh the
clips channel the dark horse podcast
clips channel
is live as well anything else there's
another
campfire united
i campfire it's tomorrow i am being
careful since i have begun announcing
things that are
not yet ready to be announced i'm going
to be vague and say
campfires will continue into the future
oh
do sign up at articlesofunity.org
given that our twitter account has been
suspended
the way to find out what's going on is
to
sign up with your email there i guess
you can also follow me on twitter and i
will try to fill in for that account
until they
reinstate it which i certainly assume
that they will but
um in any case we'll be back
in 15 minutes that's right and we will
answer your questions all right be well
everyone
you